Speaker 1: completely opposite what is going
on for Joe Biden, which has been very good.
Things are going disastrously for the failed
former president Donald Trump, who is desperate,
desperate to claim innocence and try to get
himself out of all sorts of legal trouble
and potentially justify another presidential
run in 2024. Donald Trump had a historic
meltdown yesterday on Truth Sociale declaring
himself innocent. Declaring himself innocent.
And you have to see these posts just as sort
of diarrhea of the post Donald Trump starting,
quote, Even though I am as innocent as a person
can be, and despite my campaign being spied on by
the radical left, the FISA court being lied to and
defrauded, and all of the many hoaxes and scams
that were illegally placed on me by very sick
and demented people. And without even mentioning
the many crimes of Joe and Hunter Biden all
revealed in great detail in the laptop from hell.
It looks more and more like the fake
news media is pushing hard for the sleaze
to do something that should not be done. That's an
insane message. It is nuts that a former president
typed out that message and posted it publicly.
There are probably ten lies and distortions in
that short message. And by the way, Trump saying
that he is as innocent as anyone has ever been
to me suggests he's guilty now. This isn't a
court of law. I'm not suggesting Trump be denied
due process. This is the court of common sense
many things. The more strongly Trump claims a,
the more likely the opposite of is
likely to be true. And Trump's kind
of interesting in that he's very direct in
that sense. Many politicians will equivocate
and they'll play semantics, or they'll kind of
massage facts or distract and muddy the waters.
When Trump's guilty, he'll just come out and
say, I'm innocent. That's been the theme.
Trump continuing to post, quote, Joe Biden said
he knew nothing about the break in of Mar a Lago
or the greatest political attack in the history
of the U.S. Does anybody really believe this? Now,
there is no evidence Biden knew anything.
And of course, it wasn't a break in. It was
a search warrant signed by the attorney general,
okayed by Trump's own FBI director appointee,
and a judge signed off on it. So again, all lies
Trump continuing, quote, the radical left Democrat
prosecutors are illegally trying to circumvent
for purely political gain the Presidential
Records Act, under which I have done absolutely
nothing wrong. It cannot be circumvented for me
or any other president. They illegally raided my
home untrue and took things that should not have
been taken untrue. They even broke into my safe
an unthinkable act. Well, the safe was listed
in the search warrant. Everything was perfectly
legal. Trump then resorting to just tweeting or
I'm sorry, not tweeting tro thing in all caps.
Presidential Records Act. Trump then posting,
quote, the justice department and FBI are,
quote, leaking at levels never seen before.
And I did nothing wrong. I think Trump's brain
is leaking at levels never seen before. And then
Donald Trump also putting out a statement which is
crazy, which says Joe Biden and the radical left
Democrats have just orchestrated another election
enhancing money grab this time to the tune of $300
billion. And just like I predicted, it's coming
right out of the pocket of the working class
Americans who are struggling the most crippling
inflation, unaffordable energy prices and war,
all things that should have never happened. But
if that wasn't enough, now Americans are bailing
out college administrators who fleeced students
and who opted for degrees there was no way they
could afford. America is a nation in decline and
the cliff into oblivion is within sight. Stop
voting for Democrats. Make America great again. A
miss clear, very inspirational message from Donald
Trump. It is not normal for anybody. It when your
neighbor flips out on social media like this,
it's cause for alarm. This is a failed former
president doing it and it's incredibly humiliating